und jetzt das heute journal
windsurfer richter und christian sievers
in allen guten abend der bundespräsident
ist geimpft mit astrazeneca das war
gesundheitsschutz und politisches
statement zugleich die hausärzte sollen
jetzt großflächig mit dem impfen
loslegen auch wenn ihnen für einen
echten durchbruch nach wie vor die
impfstoffe fehlen und vor den praktikern
vor ort in deutschlands impfzentren hört
man viel sorge bei den menschen die dazu
ihnen kommen viele diskussionen viel
überzeugungsarbeit viel
informationsbedarf
dieses land hat über ostern einiges zu
tun daniel ponce dem besonderen
vertrauensverhältnis von dem derzeit so
viel die rede ist zwischen hausarzt und
patient hier kann man ihm nachspüren
seit jahrzehnten führt wolf rüdiger
becker seine praxis impfen zählt er zu
seinen ureigensten aufgaben natürlich
auch jetzt sagt er endlich geht es los
die bestellten 30 portion hat der
apotheker grad angerufen kommen nächste
woche auch am dienstag so wenn wir den
impfstoff in der hand haben haben wir ja
unsere liste von patienten über 85 80
jährige und dann auch die 70 jährigen
und mit der möbel gehöre und priorität
insgesamt 35.000 arztpraxen bundesweit
inklusive der wie hier bereits in
pilotprojekten beteiligten sollen nach
ostern zum zentralen faktor werden in
jener großen gleichung an deren ende ein
durchgehendes deutschland stehen soll
bestellt hatten die praxen für nächste
woche 1,4 millionen dosen erhalten
werden sie erst einmal 940.000 und
trotzdem nach all den rückschlägen
zuletzt klang der gemeinsame auftritte
am prozess beteiligten heute wie ein
kollektives jetzt aber für die impfstoff
logistik kann ich ihnen zuversicht geben
auch wenn es aufgrund der verfügbaren
impfstoff menge langsam anlaufen wird es
wird verlässlich sein
wir starten jetzt in den ersten beiden
wochen also nächste und übernächste
woche mit biontech ausschließlich für
die arztpraxen und dann ab der kw 16 der
woche danach wird bei und tag und astra
zenica in die arztpraxen gehen und ab
kalenderwoche 17
beyoncé kastration iker und johnson &
johnson wir starten mit der verteilung
ab dienstag nächster woche und werden
dort zirka wie bereits erwähnt 940.000
dosen verteilen
unsere kapazitäten sind bereits heute
darauf ausgelegt weitaus höhere mengen
zu verarbeiten dass die wechselnden
empfehlungen zu astrazeneca unsicherheit
erzeugt und sei bedauerlich aber
zwangsläufige ergebnis der jeweiligen
datenlage gewesen hieß es heute
und prinzipiell müsste man zur kenntnis
nehmen impfungen könnten genau wie
medikamente stets nebenwirkungen
verursachen
astrazeneca passiere dies stand jetzt im
vergleich aber nach wie vor sehr selten
wenn sie sich den normalen beipackzettel
eines nicht steroidalen antirheumatika
muss oder einer pille eines
operationssaals anschauen werden sie in
deutlich höheren größenordnung gleich
schwere risiken feststellen da macht
keiner großes bohei und mal nehmen sie
mal wieder grad da stehen auch ganz
andere nebenwirkung drin das wird völlig
ignoriert ignoriert hat innenminister
horst seehofer unterdessen den wunsch
von jens spahn dass sich auch über 60
jährige spitzenpolitiker mit astrazeneca
impfen lassen mögen um vorbild zu sein
er wolle das nicht wolle sich nicht
bevormunden lassen der bundespräsident
dagegen ließ sich heute impfen mit
astrazeneca nachdem auch er durch die
neue stiko empfehlung mit an der reihe
war
impfen ist das eine mittel im kampf
gegen die pandemie das erfolgreich ist
und gleichzeitig mit rückschlägen kämpft
testen ist das andere
diese kleinen plastik kästen auf denen
sich dann eine linie zeigt und
hoffentlich nicht zwei gehören schon
fast selbstverständlich zum alltag
gehören auf jeden fall zum vokabular
aller politiker unternehmer
verbandsvertreter die hände ringend
alternative suchen zum simplen alles
aufmachen oder alles schließen
und dennoch bleiben auch hier viele
fragen antworten jetzt von christian von
rechenberg und anna maria schuck
frankfurt gurgelt seit einer woche gibt
es neben den klassischen teststationen
nun eine weitere zum durchfahren ohne
stäbchen stattdessen mit flüssigkeit pcr
oder anti gen test sie bieten beides die
ergebnisse gibt's aufs handy der test
wird in österreich schon sehr lange
durchgeführt die erste untersuchung
gehen auf märz 2020 zurück er super
verlässlich und natürlich für den
anwender total angenehm ob mit stäbchen
oder ohne wieviel teststationen es zur
zeit gibt es nicht exakt erfasst das
saarland schätzt knapp 360 sachsen
mindestens 640 baden württemberg rund
2000 nrw habe 6500 einen schnelltest pro
woche zahlt der staat wenn sie einmal
zum friseur wollen vielleicht auch mal
ins theater oder ins kino
da ist einmal die woche zu wenig das
heißt die schlagzahl muss erhöht werden
und zwar flächendeckend fürs frei testen
für lockerungen
das ist eine strategie aber auch die
richtige klüger wäre laut experten mit
den tests zunächst gezielt nach
ansteckenden menschen zu finden die
positiven finden nicht die negativen
dafür gebe es schon jetzt genug tests
das wichtigste ist jetzt sehr breit zu
testen und zwar in den bereichen wo die
kontakte sowieso stattfinden nämlich in
schulen und in präsenz betreten in kitas
wird in der regel nur das personal
getestet oder besucher die kinder meist
nicht mit wenigen ausnahmen etwa in
berlin oder sachsen anhalt es gibt
modellprojekte wie etwa in dieser kita
in osnabrück die eltern nehmen tests mit
nach hause und testen ob kinder
überhaupt damit klarkommen an den
schulen wollen alle länder nach den
osterferien zwei tests pro woche
anbieten für schüler und lehrkräfte
millionen testkits seien bestellt die
meisten testen in der schule nicht zu
hause obwohl das sicherer wären dafür
freiwillig nur in nrw sachsen und
schleswig holstein sind die tests
pflicht in bayern bei hoher inzidenz
hat sich in den studien gezeigt dass
zwei mal testen pro woche schon
ausreichte um cluster zu verhindern also
richtige ausbrüche in den schulen die
wirtschaft versucht es mit einer
selbstverpflichtung wie gut das gelingt
zeigt eine umfrage
gut zwei wochen alt im schnitt bieten 19
prozent aller betriebe testern 28
prozent wollen dass in kürze und mehr
als die hälfte testet nicht das liege
zum teil an home office zum teil an
ungelösten probleme woher bekommt man
tests wer macht den test bei der firma
knoll in sachsen macht der chef der hat
eigentlich andere sorgen doch in sachsen
ist testpflicht wie auch in berlin
die könnte jetzt sogar bundesweit kommt
man die kanzlerin
sehr zum ärger der branchenvertreter man
wolle ja testen
die bereitschaft sei da wir stellen
allerdings auch fest der markt ist leer
gekauft wir können auch nur die tests
unseren mitarbeitern anbieten die auch
vorhanden sind deswegen alle vorsicht
von der wirtschaft nicht mehr zu
verlangen als der staat in der lage ist
zu leisten wo steht deutschland an zu
beim testen
bestenfalls befriedigend so einer
unserer gesprächspartner mit viel luft
nach oben
erst ein tusch der nationalhymne dann
erscheint emanuele makro auf den
bildschirmen von lidl bis perpignan
knetet seine hände schaut eindringlich
beugt sich richtung kamera vor und es
ist bereits klar er hat keine guten
nachrichten für sein land
ganz frankreich muss in einen neuen
lockdown und zwar einen echten
mehr als zehn kilometer darf sich
niemand mehr von seinem wohnort
entfernen
abends und nachts gar nicht mehr raus
besonders hart die schulen schließen
wieder erst mal für drei wochen
frankreich hat bereits viel durchgemacht
hoffnung haben auf die zukunft fällt
schwer
und auch der präsident wirkt zunehmend
ratlos wenn ich den epidemiologen zu
höre muss ich den lockdown beschließen
sagt er
wenn ich den psychiatern zuhöre müsste
alles auf bleiben aus paris christel
haas
es ist seine neunte große rede seit
beginn der krise und sie dürfte dem
präsidenten nicht leicht gefallen sein
was er verkündet ist eine kurskorrektur
schulen offen halten nur regionale
corona maßnahmen das war bislang das
credo
jetzt die kehrtwende wir müssen das
virus ausbremsen alle kindergärten
schulen und gymnasien werden für drei
wochen geschlossen und das ist nicht
alles die verschärften chor ohne regeln
die bereits in mehreren départements
unter anderem in paris in kraft sind
gelten ab samstag landesweit vier wochen
lang heißt nicht lebensnotwendige
geschäfte müssen schließen raus darf man
nur in einem umkreis von wenigen
kilometern sie vor ist unsere bisherigen
maßnahmen reichen nicht aus durch die
englische mutation hat sich die epidemie
weiter beschleunigt wenn wir jetzt nicht
handeln
verlieren wir die kontrolle die
krankenhäuser sind wieder am limit in
dieser notaufnahme müssen die korona
patienten oft stundenlang im gang warten
weil kein zimmer frei ist
auch die intensivstationen schlagen
einer jeden tag kommen 20 bis 30 neue
patienten
das sind deutlich mehr als betten zur
verfügung stehen und die zahl der
neuinfektionen steigt weiter die sieben
tage incidents liegt weit über 300 jetzt
werden die zügel angezogen die franzosen
zwischen frust und verständnis es geht
nicht anders
es ist sogar schon ein bisschen zu spät
dafür wenn man die experten so hört es
ist keine gute lösung die schule zu
schließen und die kinder nicht mehr zu
unterrichten
wir stecken ja alle fest wir müssen
akzeptieren was sie entscheiden
man fragt uns sowieso nicht im parlament
lässt die opposition kein gutes haar an
merkels krisenmanagement
zehntausende wenn nicht hunderttausende
einzelhändler die jetzt schließen müssen
werden in den ruin geschickt hier wird
weder sinnvoll noch intelligent
gehandelt impfen impfen impfen ist die
strategie auf die der präsident jetzt
alles setzt bis ende juli sollen alle
erwachsenen mindestens eine dosis
erhalten haben es ist ein wettlauf mit
der zeit und mit dem virus den immer
will man gewinnen muss will er seine
glaubwürdigkeit behalten
vor einem jahr hatte man dem virus noch
den krieg erklärt der krieg ist alles
andere als gewonnen christel hsg nahm
nach paris wir kennen die diskussionen
hier bei uns in deutschland wie sehr
steht denn der französische präsident
unter druck was seine corona politik
angeht na ja der krieg ist noch nicht
ganz verloren aber der präsident hat
natürlich ordentlich federn lassen
müssen
da war zunächst die masters masten chaos
zu beginn der krise dann der schleppende
im stadt- und jetzt durfte er vor dem
kurs abrücken den eigenmächtig
beschlossen hat entgegen allen
empfehlungen nämlich nur regionale
corona maßnahmen zu ergreifen und die
schulen offen zu lassen
außerdem wächst die kritik am
präsidenten und zwar am führungsstil des
präsidenten der oft das parlament außen
vor lässt also der druck ist erheblich
im manual makro muss jetzt zeigen dass
er die krise noch meistern kann und gut
meistern kann
auch im hinblick aufs nächste jahr denn
dann stehen präsidentschaftswahlen an
dann gucken wir noch mal kurz auf die
französinnen und franzosen christel ein
letztes mal noch ein letztes mal noch
lockdown hat makro jetzt versprochen
haben denn seine worte nach autorität
ziehen die franzosen da jetzt mit es
gibt eine aktuelle umfrage die vieles
erklärt 70 prozent der franzosen
unterstützen die neuen maßnahmen aber 46
prozent wollen sich nicht daran halten
das zeigt das dilemma in dem die
menschen hier sind sie wissen auf der
einen seite dass etwas getan werden muss
auf der anderen seite haben sie die nase
voll von ständig neuen beschränkungen
das gute und das positive für die
franzosen hier
das makro gestern keinen harten rock
band verkündet hat so wie damals vor
einem jahr
da ist die wirtschaft fast zum
stillstand gekommen und man durfte nur
für eine stunde am tag raus dass wenn
das gekommen wäre hätten viele das so
nicht mittragen wollen und solange es
diesen knallharten lockdown nicht gibt
werden die franzosen wohl wenn auch
widerwillig ihren präsidenten folgen
das glas live aus paris herzlichen dank
was ist ein knallharter lockdown auch da
sehr interessant die unterschiede
zwischen den verschiedenen ländern
frankreich und deutschland so kein
besonders hoffnungsvolles bild auch bei
unseren nachbarn in österreich aktuell
kurz vor ostern bereits viele
intensivstationen belegt deshalb gehen
drei bundesländer in einem mehrtägigen
schatten in niederösterreich wien und
dem burgenland gelten nun rund um die
uhr ausgangs beschränkungen
außerdem schließen die meisten geschäfte
museen und zoos die sieben tage
incidents liegt in diesen gebieten
zwischen 280 und 340 nicht nur in
deutschland läuft die impfkampagne
schleppend laut der
weltgesundheitsorganisation müsste ganz
europa deutlich schneller impfen
die geschwindigkeit sei inakzeptabel
langsam so der zuständige direktor kluge
die infektions lage in europa seien so
besorgniserregend wie seit monaten nicht
mehr um die mutationen unter kontrolle
zu bringen seien mehr tests und
quarantänemaßnahmen nötig der pflege
bevollmächtigte der bundesregierung
westerfellhaus warnt vor einer
massenflucht aus dem pflegeberuf viele
beschäftigte sehen sich nach
alternativen um sagte er dem redaktions
netzwerk deutschland nach über einem
jahr dauer stress seien viele körperlich
und seelisch erschöpft es müsse ein
personalschlüssel her der sich am
tatsächlichen pflegebedarf orientiert
und an der leistungsfähigkeit der
beschäftigten in baden württemberg
wollen die grünen koalitionsgespräche
mit der cdu aufnehmen das hat der
landesvorstand entschieden allerdings
erst nach zähem ringen
einige mitglieder hatten starke
vorbehalte gegen das bündnis geäußert
für das vor allem ministerpräsident
kretschmann ein
rechnerisch wäre auch eine
ampelkoalition mit spd und fdp möglich
die un-sondergesandte für myanmar
schraner burgener hat vor einem
bürgerkrieg dort gewarnt hintergrund sei
das harte vorgehen des militärs sie
appellierte an den un sicherheitsrat
eine so wörtlich katastrophe im herzen
asiens zu verhindern
auch heute gingen soldaten gewaltsam
gegen demonstranten vor
dabei sollen zwei menschen getötet und
viele weitere verletzt worden seien
am abend gedachten bürger yang gon der
menschen die seit dem militärputsch vor
genau zwei monaten ums leben kamen
aktivisten sprechen von mehr als 500
toten ein land zwei systeme das war nie
eine wirklich auf ewig garantierte basis
für das verhältnis von hongkong und
china
aber es war die grundlage dafür dass sie
wenigstens in hongkong sagen konnten was
sie dachten und schreiben konnten was
ist das war einmal
pekings sicherheitsgesetz gilt jetzt in
hongkong und die damit verbundenen
befürchtungen bestätigen sich heute
sieben führende kämpfer für die
demokratie sind verurteilt worden
darunter der prominente medien
unternehmer und verleger jimmy lee auf
der rangliste der pressefreiheit ist
hongkong dramatisch abgestürzt china
steht dort sowieso schon ganz hinten
wer die freiheit liebt sieht immer
häufiger keinen anderen ausweg als zu
gehen
ulf röller berichtet familie chen packt
die koffer
sie verlässt hongkong für immer wir
dürfen ihre gesichter nicht zeigen denn
sie haben angst dass chinas machthaber
versuchen
festzuhalten es ist eine sehr harte
entscheidung die stadt freunde und die
familie zu verlassen
ihr sohn ist während der proteste zur
welt gekommen er soll in freiheit
aufwachsen aber in hongkong eine
kommunistische erziehung
sie werden das schulsystem in hongkong
verändern
dann würden sie meinen sohn irgendwann
eine gehirnwäsche unterziehen
seit wochen jagt in der stadt ein
schauprozess den anderen
heute stehen unter anderem der verleger
jimmy lee und der bekannte
oppositionspolitiker long corp genannt
lang her vor gericht der vorwurf
teilnahme an einer illegalen
demonstration es droht gefängnis
wir fragen die frau von long her wie es
ihrem mann geht weil er in
untersuchungshaft ist können wir ihn
jeden tag besuchen er ist gesund sagt
seine frau er wirkt ruhig er zeit zu
schreiben und zu lesen
sie haben noch geheiratet bevor er ins
gefängnis musste auf dem regal stehen
ein paar bilder von einem leben das dem
kampf gegen chinas machthaber gewidmet
ist schon öfter wallon er eingesperrt
aber diesmal fürchtet seine frau könnte
er für sehr lange weg sein denn sie
haben ihn auch wegen verschwörung
angeklagt
ich versuche darüber nicht nachzudenken
der verstoß gegen das nationale
sicherheitsgesetz wird mit mindestens
fünf jahren bestraft
das urteil schuldig das strafmaß wird
später verkündet lang her bleibt im
gefängnis seine frau nach der
verhandlung mit nur einer einzigen
botschaft lasst alle politischen
gefangenen frei es wird nicht passieren
während chinas machthaber die opposition
ab urteilt packt irgendwo in der stadt
eine familie ihre koffer hongkong hat
für sie keine zukunft mehr
der erfahrene bbc korrespondent john
scott werve hat hals über kopf china
verlassen aus angst um seine sicherheit
und um seine familie
john's arbeit hat wahrheiten enthüllt
von denen die chinesischen behörden
nicht wollten dass die welt sie weiß
sagt die bbc sie sagt auch satt werve
arbeiter jetzt von taiwan aus und er
bleibt unser china korrespondent nochmal
kaiser jetzt mit antworten auf die
korona krise aus deutschland einerseits
und aus den usa zunächst die antwort der
bundesregierung sie will unternehmen
besser unterstützen die besonders schwer
von der krise betroffen sind
wer seit november mindestens drei monate
lang umsatzeinbrüche von mehr als 50
prozent erlitten hat kann nun neue oder
höhere zuschüsse beantragen weitere
nachbesserungen gibt es für die
veranstaltungs kultur und reisebranche
sowie für großhändler mit einem
gigantischen investitionsprogramm will
us-präsident beiden die amerikanische
infrastruktur ausbauen und millionen
arbeitsplätze schaffen
dafür soll der kongress rund 2,3
billionen dollar freigeben
zwar sind die republikaner dort noch
nicht überzeugt trotzdem feiert schon
die finanzwelt was genau versprechen
sich die anleger valerie haller an der
frankfurter börse
jede menge versprechen sie sich nicht
nur die anleger in den usa auch hier
setzt man darauf dass für deutsche
unternehmer aufträge winken wenn die
amerikaner derart viel geld in die hand
nehmen
die amerikanische infrastruktur hat es
bitter nötig vieles stammt noch aus den
50er jahren brücken straßen
kanalisationen zum teil völlig veraltet
beiden will ein moderneres ein grüneres
amerika millionen arbeitsplätze soll das
programm schaffen
insgesamt 2,3 billionen dollar ist das
paket schwer geld für 32.000 kilometer
straße 10 tausend brücken mehrere
flughäfen und
elektromobilität es wäre vermutlich das
größte job programm seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg und das erste mal dass die usa
die energiewende zum kernthema einer
wirtschaftsreform machen das
konjunkturpaket muss aber noch durch die
instanzen die stoffe chancen stehen
nicht schlecht die demokraten haben eine
knappe mehrheit in beiden kammern die
börse freut sich jetzt schon der dax ist
kräftig im plus und damit auf einem
neuen rekordhoch
streitpunkt zwischen demokraten und
republikanern ist vor allem die
finanzierung beiden will sein
konjunkturprogramm mit höheren
unternehmens steuern bezahlen damit
nimmt er ein stück weit zurück was trump
angestoßen hatte steuererleichterungen
für die wirtschaft
vielen dank valerie doch nicht nur die
finanzwelt hofft auf ein anziehen der
weltwirtschaft sondern auch die
ölexporteure sie erwarten eine steigende
nachfrage und wollen daher ihre
fördermengen ausweiten
wegen der chor oder bedingten schwachen
nachfrage hatte die sogenannte opec plus
gruppe ihre produktion gedrosselt
zuletzt war der ölpreis aber wieder
deutlich gestiegen
das zweite jahr in folge steht der
gründonnerstag im zeichen der korona
pandemie auch für papst franziskus der
die osterfeierlichkeiten nur mit wenigen
gläubigen begeht wie hier bei der
sogenannten chrisam messe im petersdom
dabei segnete er die heiligen öle die im
laufe des jahres verwendet werden
ein grund donnerstag endet die 40 tägige
fastenzeit
die welt dreht sich immer schneller die
mühlen des gesetzes mahlen langsam
es gibt kein grundrecht auf gesunde
umwelt auf faire produkte kein
grundrecht auf schutz vor manipulation
durch digital konzerne
kurz gesagt europas grundrechte brauchen
dringend ein update so hat sich das der
jurist und bestseller autor ferdinand
von schirach gedacht und gleich
losgelegt und wie kern ist ein kleines
buch im grunde aber geht es ihm um ein
projekt bei dem wir alle mitmachen
sollen
jeder mensch bei dem sich europa
erinnert an seine werte und an sich
selbst
christian kirsch stellt uns das vor
wir treffen ferdinand von schirach im
tiergarten in berlin
schirach jurist und autor will erläutern
was ihnen dazu treibt die charta der
grundrechte der europäischen union zu
erweitern und das gleich um sechs
artikeln
die mütter und väter beispielsweise des
grundgesetzes wussten nichts vom
internet sie kannten keine sozialen
medien sie konnten sich keine
algorithmen vorstellen und keine
künstliche intelligenz sie dachten nicht
an den klimawandel oder daran dass
präsidenten so dauerhaft und
systematisch lügen das alles ist sind
unsere erfahrungen unserer zeit und das
sagt von schirach muss jetzt folgen
haben die moderne verlange auch nach
juristischem fortschritt grundlegendes
recht fortgeschrieben in die gegenwart
jeder mensch hat das recht in einer
gesunden und geschützten umwelt zu leben
jeder mensch hat das recht auf digitale
selbstbestimmung die ausforschung oder
manipulation von menschen ist verboten
jeder mensch hat das recht das ihn
belastende algorithmen transparent
überprüfbar und fair sind wesentliche
entscheidungen muss ein mensch treffen
neue grundrechte im digitalzeitalter in
einer zeit der künstlichen intelligenz
in der im grunde niemand mehr den
überblick haben kann darüber was rechner
über ihn oder sie speichern bewerten
oder weiterleiten allerdings sind solche
artikel wirklich von nöten
datenschutzrecht etwa gibt es ja bereits
also kein rechtliches niemandsland
selbstverständlich gibt es da
einschlägige gesetze und auch regelungen
auch auf verfassungsrechtlicher ebene
aber in den ganzen bereichen die hier in
diesen neuen sechs artikeln geregelt
sind haben wir es mit so revolutionären
entwicklungen zu tun oder mit sohn ein
phänomen das man eben damit auch
gesetzgeberisch unmittelbar darauf
reagieren muss und eben sechs neue
menschenrechte verabschieden sollte
jeder mensch
hat das recht dass äußerungen von
amtsträgern der wahrheit entsprechen
jeder mensch hat das recht dass ihm nur
solche waren und dienstleistungen
angeboten werden die unter wahrung der
universellen menschenrechte hergestellt
und erbracht werden
jeder mensch kann wegen systematischer
verletzungen dieser charta
grundrechtsklage von den europäischen
gerichten erheben
äußerungen von amtsträgern sollten
einklagbar der wahrheit entsprechen
ein problem sei dass politik gibt der
ehemalige us-präsident etwa soll mehr
als 30.000 mal in seiner amtszeit die
wahrheit er flexibel gestaltet haben
neue rechte für eine neue zeit welche
grundrechte erfordert diese gegenwart
schirach stellt drängende fragen und er
fordert eine debatte über neue werte
europas es gibt großartige verfassung in
europa nichts davon soll angegriffen
werden es soll nur erweitert werden also
der verbeulte rahmen in der durch die
großen herausforderungen und
verwerfungen der moderne entstanden ist
der muss eben repariert werden jeder
mensch kann bald abstimmen im internet
shiraz ziel ein grundrechts konvent und
damit vielleicht neue grundrechte für
die menschen europas wir bleiben dran
erstmal ist am ostersamstag das
heute-journal team wieder für sie da und
für heute herzlichen dank fürs zuschauen
nach einem weichen wach bleiben dann
freut sich einer zimmermann auf sie um
kurz nach halb eins
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren heute nacht
fällt am alpenrand und auch im
erzgebirge etwas regen sonst ist es
häufig klar und die temperaturen sinken
auf 8 grad am oberrhein und bis minus
ein grad in der lüneburger heide
morgen ist es meist april frisch mit
höchsttemperaturen zwischen acht und
zwölf grad und nur im süden hält sich
noch ein bisschen was von der wärme bei
13 bis 18 grad
das wird ein freundlicher karfreitag
sonne und wolken wechseln sich ab bei
einem lebhaften zum teil kräftigen wind
aus nordwestlichen richtungen an
karsamstag droht eine kleine weiße
überraschung hier im erzgebirge oder
auch im oberpfälzer bayerischen wald da
schneit es bis auf 600 meter runter der
ostersonntag wird dann sonnig und am
ostermontag wird es von nordwesten
deutlich wechselhafter und auch wenn es
jetzt von tag zu tag kälter wird die
frühlingsboten sind ja unübersehbar zum
beispiel zitronenfalter meist die ersten
weil sie als fertige falter hängend im
gebüsch überwintern kleiner fuchs und
takt frauen auge verkriechen sich lieber
im warmen schmetterlinge können ihre
körpertemperatur nämlich nicht selber
regeln
sie sind abhängig von ihrer
umgebungstemperatur und können durch
geschickte flügel stellung
sonnenstrahlen umlenken oder sich so zur
sonne drehen dass sie nur ganz wenige
strahlen treffen was die falter mögen
sind ungefüllten blüten und eine
vielfältige umgebung
da ist die landwirtschaft gefragt aber
auch wir wenn wir balkon und garten
bepflanzt
was schmetterlinge schützt nützt auch
anderen insekten die wiederum sind
wichtig weil sie 85 prozent der
nutzpflanzen des menschen besteht
guten abend